[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim sportreport dem
Sportplatz des österreichischen
Bundesheers heute zu Gast Frau Zugführer
Katharina Schützenhöfer und Frau
Zugführer Lena meine Damen herzlich
willkommen ja danke für die Einladung
wir freuen können
schon gesehen ihr seid Österreichs top
Beachvolleyball Team bei den Damen seid
also gemeinsam über unterwegs und seit
sehr erfolgreich erst vor kurzem aus
einer der schönsten Locations dieser
Welt aber eben nicht auf Urlaub gewesen
sondern erfolgreich zurückgekommen was
auf dem Malediven was habt ihr denn dort
gemacht
und man muss schon sagen es war das
erste Mal dass Anthony wirklich ein so
einem Ort ist also es war wirklich mit
Abstand der schönste Ort in dem wir
jemals gespielt haben und es ist
wirklich die urlaubslocation mehr oder
weniger Hanni und Location und ja es war
wirklich traumhaft also ja und auch sehr
erfolgreich wie gesagt das war ein
Challenger Turnier das zweithöchste in
der turnierkategorie und wir sind im
zweiten waren bis ins Finale kommen und
dort nur ganz knapp verloren aber es war
bis jetzt mit Abstand der beste ist am
Ergebnis und ja das extrem stolz darauf
vor allem sind wichtige Punkte für den
Status in Olympia-Qualifikation startet
und ja das Wichtigste war wir haben
einfach eine extrem starke Leistung
zeigt bei diesen Sommer heuer ein
bisschen durchwachsen wenn wir wieder
gut gespielt und das wird das erste
Video wirklich irgendwann ganz noch nie
Verlauf sehr sehr gut gespielt haben und
ja wir sind echt mega happy
bei dem Challenger Turnier ich war im
September auf den Malediven aufhören
Flitterwochen
ich kann also
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
abgelenkt oder die Versuchung groß dass
man sich dann doch auf die schöne Sonne
und auf den schönen Strand konzentriert
und nicht auf weil spielen nein
überhaupt nicht also ich glaube das
immer wirklich mittlerweile
professionell genug und wissen warum wir
dorthin fliegen und natürlich haben wir
die Zeit abseits vom Training und vom
Turnier genossen aber wir sind da
wirklich ganz klar mit einem Ziel
hingeflogen und haben gesagt coole
Destination aber der Fokus ist natürlich
das Turnier und das immer wirklich
mittlerweile glaube ich ja erwachsen
genug nein für das coole daran war ja
wir sind ja Sonntag früh ankommen und
das Sonntag war da noch frei zum
regenerieren und da war perfektes Wetter
und dann war ich die ganze Turnier Woche
über von Montag bis Sonntag es war
extrem regnerisch es war nur ein zwei
Stunden am Tag schön und von dem hat
perfekt gepasst wir haben gearbeitet und
das Wetter aber nicht perfekt und doch
dass wir soweit kommen sind haben wir
neuen Flug gebraucht und haben dann den
Montag sozusagen noch mal dort frei
gehabt in dem Montag drauf und da war
das Wetter wieder perfekt also so sehen
ja aber das ist unser Job und wir sind
ja auch froh wenn man bei Traumwetter
einfach am konvolleyball spielen das
macht uns Spaß das macht uns Freude und
wir sehen uns ja nicht die Ideen den
ganzen Tag am Strand nur liegen wollen
ist ja dort derzeit die Regenzeit ich
bin noch gute informiert aber wenn ihr
sagt das jetzt auch noch ein paar
Sonnenstunden ist auf jeden Fall gut
dass du mir gespielt und erschwerten
Bedingungen und so erfolgreich gewesen
ich habe das vorher gesagt die
zweithöchste Ebene das hat sich ja
geändert der
Weltverband hat er die Struktur ein
bisschen verändert von den Turnieren
findet ihr das gut findet ihr das
schlecht kommt euch das entgegen es gibt
ja auch von beiden Seiten Meinungen für
die neue Form ich glaube wir sind ein
bisschen zwiegespalten in dem gegenüber
weil also früher dann die
Kategorisierung von Einstein bis fünf
Sternen geben im fünf Turnier Kategorien
und bei den obersten teilen haben halt
32 Teams im Hauptbewerb starten dürfen
plusqualifikation und jetzt ist einfach
bei allen drei Kategorien insgesamt das
Teilnehmerfeld einfach kleiner geworden
das heißt bei mir liegt Turnier heißt 16
sind nur 16 Teams im Hauptbewerb bloß
halt eine Quali mit 16 Teams und bei
einem Challenge sind auch nur 24 im
Hauptbewerb plus
das heißt im großen und ganzen können in
diesen ganzen Kategorien einfach weniger
Teams teilnehmen für uns ist es
eigentlich gut wir sind übrigens
reinspiel wir können teilnehmen auch für
junge Teams die Nachkommen wann ist es
extrem schwierig überhaupt teilzunehmen
weil einfach die Teilnehmerfelder
kleiner worden sind dass ich schon
problematisch andererseits sieht man
dass die Qualifikationen bei Turnieren
jetzt auf den Malediven oder sind auch
Turniere noch in Kapstadt in Australien
die werden nicht voll sein und ich finde
da muss man halt sich die Chance nehmen
und die Chance greifen und hinfliegen ja
ansonsten ich weiß nicht ich bin so
Preisgeld technisch ist halt einfach in
den letzten 10 Jahren leider bergab
gegangen deswegen wollen sie jetzt
wieder mehr Preisgeld machen ich glaube
das ist vielleicht minimal besser
geworden ist bei mir liegt 16 weißt du
das genau nicht wirklich also wirklich
zu den früheren Grand Slams ist noch
immer schlechter sie tun soll als wäre
es wieder besser aber es ist leider
wirklich besser sie mit so einem Art
Bonus-System macht wo wenn man ab 9
Turnieren kriegt man dann eine gewisse
Prozentzahl vom Gesamtpreis Geld noch
dazu also sozusagen sie belohnen die die
viel spielen aber im Endeffekt ist
leider das Preisgeld insgesamt wirklich
viel schlechter geworden im Vergleich
zum letzten Jahren
was auch problematisch weil es ist drei
viermal der Turnierkalender geändert
worden hat ausgeschaut das ist extrem
wenig Turniere gibt auch extrem weniger
Challenge weil wir am Anfang gedacht
haben wir können bei der Elite nicht
starten wir haben dann
öfters eine Qualifikation teilgenommen
sind dann meistens in meiner Quali zu
raus aber ist halt trotzdem eigentlich
bist du dann 17 Uhr beim Turnier beim
höchstturnier was nicht schlecht ist und
da hat sich dann eh viel geändert dass
er in diese Saison sehr dicht mit
Turnieren war und von dem her finde ich
hat das dann heuer schon gepasst also
ich finde das positive und negative
Seiten die neue Form ich finde das
wichtigste ist einfach dass es mal
konsequent der gleiche Modus und die
eigene Niere bleiben dass man sich etwas
einstellen kann plus deshalb am Anfang
wollten sie das Lied 16 ohne
Qualifikation machen und das wäre finde
ich dann problematisch waren weil du nur
langfristig über die anderen Turniere
reinspielen kannst aber vor jedem
Turnier ist vier Wochen davor die
entweder Deadline das heißt da musst du
genug Punkte haben und das ändert sich
dann so schnell im Sommer einfach nicht
ist extrem schwer zu planen auch anfangs
nicht gut können wir überhaupt die Elite
spielen zuerst immer gedacht wir kommen
da nicht mal rein und dadurch das jetzt
auch nur die besten drei Ergebnisse aus
den letzten vier geben diesen zählen
kann sich das alles so so ändern und
dementsprechend ist es jetzt auch ein
bisschen schwierig weil dieses wohnen
jetzt bis Dezember geht und keiner kann
körperlich und auch mental irgendwie und
finanziell eine Saison von März bis
Dezember durchspielen mit Destinationen
Mexiko
Australien USA
maledigen also alles wirklich wo man
halt wirklich ein extremes Budget
erstens mal aufstehen muss und auch
körperlich ist einfach durchhalten muss
und das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig
finde ich weil jetzt sind noch so viele
Turniere und auch so viele Elite
Turniere die jetzt halt im Vergleich zu
Anfang das ist so extrem viel schwächer
besetzt sind und auch nicht voll sind
weiß ich einfach keiner leisten kann und
auch einfach von der Planung her einfach
nicht mehr reinpasst also das ist halt
ein bisschen finde ich aber bisschen
schwierig gerade und ich bin gespannt ob
sie wenigstens und wieder was ändern
weil es war jetzt kurz Diskussion ob es
jetzt wieder keine Qualifikation macht
bei den Turnieren was halt wirklich
extrem wäre weil dann wenn du mir 16
Teams wirklich dabei und das ist dann
halt schon schwierig also wird sich die
Spitze einzelne Tieren und von außen
weniger
Netzwerk für uns wir wieder so in der
Kippe ein bisschen sind zwischen
Challenge Elite das wir für uns halt
schon ein bisschen schlimm aber wie
gesagt und auch in Hinblick auf die
Olympia-Qualifikation weil das wenn es
dann zum fix ist okay die Top 16 können
immer die liturniere spielen und die
anderen haben mehr oder keine Chance
außer sich gewinnen vier oder fünf
Challenge
qualifizieren sich 16 über die Rangliste
und das wird wahrscheinlich fast eins zu
eins natürliches dürfen Olympia nur zwei
Pronation teilnehmen und jetzt haben sie
das Land offen gemacht das können auch
acht brasilianische Teams spielen das
ist jetzt ganz egal ja
das heißt da kommen wir auf jeden Fall
Herausforderungen auf weil
flexibel ist auch wichtig ihr habt doch
jetzt ein bisschen gezeigt mit welchen
Challenge dass man da konfrontiert ist
der einen Platz hier so eine so muss
wahrscheinlich auch mitten in der Saison
plötzlich sagen dann immer noch das Eine
Turnier wieder rein und das andere
wieder raus wie wie macht ihr das machen
oder mittendrin generell schwer weil ich
glaube im Februar einmal der Kalender
rauskommen das heißt wir haben einmal
die ganzen Trainingslager überhaupt
kurzfristig noch verschieben müssen weil
es zuerst Kaiser hat diese Sohn fand
irgendwie früher an und hat sie doch
später wieder angefangen haben wir noch
unser Trainingslager nach hinten
verschoben und wie gesagt das war auch
die Situation mit den Elite wir haben
nicht gut kommen da reinkommen nicht
rein das heißt dieses Jahr war echt ein
bisschen so ein Zwischenjahr kann man so
sagen weil ich muss zum nächstes Jahr
fängt erst die olympische Saison an und
deshalb war ja haben wir echt ein
bisschen flexibel sein müssen und haben
ein bisschen schauen müssen wir haben
uns dann ja auch nur knapp für die WM
qualifiziert das heißt das war auch ein
bisschen Punkt das war im Endeffekt dann
trotzdem das Highlight für uns ähm ja
dann hat es auch ein paar Komplikationen
mit unseren Tränen geben wir waren lange
mehr oder weniger nicht ganz so gut
betreut Trainer mäßig und deshalb war
die ganze Saison ein bisschen ja
zusammen gegangen
Operationen Krankenstand müssen und wir
dann halt im Sommer seit über 4 Monaten
schon in meinen Trainern das hätte
hatten aber keinen an die zehn
verschiedenen und nicht konsequent mit
einem Trainer was gearbeitet haben bzw
nicht mit dem Trainer Plan haben können
wir eigentlich die Planung dann genau zu
zweit gemacht haben
und das ist halt auch schwierig es ist
cool im Beachvolleyball flying
Verantwortung haben und schon viel
selber planen können und wollen aber
trotzdem ist halt besser du sprichst es
mit dem Trainer ab und deswegen haben
wir eigentlich nur noch besten Wissen
und Gewissen versucht jetzt die Turniere
auszuwählen die wir spielen und
eigentlich war trotzdem Ziel der Saison
meine gute Ausgangslage mit gut Punkte
für die nächste Saison zusammen und ich
glaube mit dem Malediven ist gelungen
also so gesehen haben wir uns das Hotel
eigentlich erreicht und auf dem letzten
Treffen
sich bewiesen dass wenn ihr das
zusammenstellt das ist funktioniert auf
den letzten wird dann ihr eure Ziele
noch gut durch bekommt
Verantwortung angesprochen wenn jetzt in
dem Fall keine dritte Person von außen
drauf schaut wie trefft ihr
Entscheidungen an der stelle ich mir ein
Bild von der wahnsinnig komplett vor
wenn man gemeinsam im Team für den
Erfolg des Teams aber vielleicht auch
oftmals auch andere Meinungen hat wie
man zu diesem Erfolg kommt wie treffen
Entscheidungen ja ich glaube schon dass
wir mittlerweile extrem genau wissen
also was uns gut tut und wir haben ja
auch schon sehr viel Erfahrung ich meine
ich bin jetzt zehn Jahre eigentlich
zusammen und wir haben auch so auf der
Welt da schon extrem viel Erfahrung
gemacht und haben schon viele Saisonen
gemeinsam erlebt und wissen
ja man kann es eh nicht immer voraus
planen weil dann kommen irgendwelche
Sachen dazwischen mit Verletzungen oder
was weiß ich im Endeffekt glaube ich
haben wir ein extrem gute
Kommunikationsbasis und wir haben uns
auch halt individuell und persönlich
extrem weiterentwickelt was auch unsere
Kommunikation betrifft und ich glaube
wenn meine extrem gute Basis eben wie
gesagt und dementsprechend setzt man uns
dann echt hin und sagen okay wie
schaut's aus was spricht dafür spricht
dagegen eigentlich ist es dann schon so
dass wir nie in Streit enden sondern das
einfach immer eine vernünftige
Diskussion ist und wenn es dann meistens
aufgrund der Fakten einige werden und
eigentlich sind in jeglicher Hinsicht
also von den letzten Jahren sind extrem
harmonisch ich meine natürlich gibt's
immer wie gesagt Diskussionen oder
einmal hat die Lena eine andere Meinung
als ich aber im Endeffekt wenn man
begründen kann und darüber redet dann
klappt das immer sehr gut auf jeden Fall
für nächstes Jahr hat sich einiges
vorgenommen olympiaqualiation
angesprochen was steht euch denn bevor
damit die Olympiaqualifikation
funktioniert für Drucker hat sich sehr
knapp nicht ausgegangen also was
hauptsächlich dafür Paris vorgenommen
auf jeden Fall es läuft bei uns so ab
dass jetzt ab 1 jänner ich glaube bis
Juni 20 über eineinhalb Jahre kann man
eben Resultate sammeln und von allem was
man dann gespielt hat zählen die besten
12 Ergebnisse wenn die Punkte einfach
summiert und dann müssen wir unter den
Top 16 bzw ein Platz für eine
Weltmeister und einen Top 15 der Welt
sein genau und deswegen muss man ja auch
ein bisschen z.B nächstes Jahr die
Weltmeisterschaft im Oktober sehr sehr
spät waren wir unseren Fokus legen oder
zum Beispiel wenn jetzt wenn jetzt
nächstes Jahr werden im Herbst dann im
schwächer besetzte dann fliegen überall
hin weil das sind dann genau die Chance
wo wir uns die guten Punkte holen können
auf jeden Fall ist eine Mischung sein
aus viel spielen aber auch immer wieder
gezielte Pausen machen dass wir bei den
ähm Turnieren 14 und dann hoffen wir
dass wir in diesen einhalb Jahren und
diese 12 guten Ergebnisse spielen oder
dabei sind notfalls gibt's wieder diesen
also kontinentalcup wo Europa sich einen
Platz ausspielt und der startet auch
schon im Frühjahr Sie mehrere Runden und
da muss man dann den kontinentalkabinen
europagrinnen wo das Finale auch erst im
Juni 24 ist genau das ist so die Route
aber das heißt im Endeffekt wenn es über
den Content habt dann gehen würde weiß
man erst anderthalb Monate vor dem
Spielen
die Deadline über die Weltrangliste und
wenn man sich eben dann nicht
qualifiziert hat ist kurz darauf dass
Europa Finale wo man eben dann den Platz
noch Schauspieler war letztes Jahr
glaube ich auch Anfang oder zweite
gleich oder so eigentlich
Teams gegangen also es ist wirklich sehr
sehr kurzfristig dann ja ist auch
schwierig dann die Form Planung zu
machen
deswegen ja der Plan ist genau
wissen wir sind dabei und fertig dann
brauchen wir nicht flexibel sein
früher desto besser die Planbarkeit ist
dann da ich habe gesagt schon sehr lange
gemeinsam wir hatten der begonnen puh
ich glaube 2010 haben unser erstes
gemeinsames
Inter und dass sie mir tatsächlich ja
vom Nationalteam Trainer
zusammengesteckt worden und der hat
gesagt hier spielst das einmal wir
wollen einmal schauen wie das harmoniert
ja Jahrgang und das ist halt im
Beachvolleyball
Meisterschaften Weltmeisterschaften
spielen kann und wir sind hier wirklich
ich bin nur ein Wochen älter als die
Lena also wir sind noch fast gleich alt
und von dem er hat das gesagt damals
unser national dem Trainer gesagt hier
Spiel zusammen könnte harmonieren ja und
das hat tatsächlich auch vom ersten Tag
an Amort und auch abseits vom chords
sehr sehr gut harmoniert wem würdest du
mir gleich gewonnen
ja und dann war eigentlich relativ
schnell klar ich glaube dann haben wir
im gleichen Jahr noch die U18 em genau
erwartet und verdammt eigentlich klar ja
läuft nicht so schlecht
das heißt es war also nicht das
professionelle Umfeld hat die Lehrerin
wo ich schon seit
und genau im Sommer haben wir halt
gebietscht und nicht so genau gewusst
was wir drauf haben wo das hinführt
genau dann war zwei elf dann waren unser
erstes wirklich sehr sehr erfolgreiches
Jahr weil dann sind wir U20
Europameister geworden in Tel Aviv und
bei der U19 Weltmeisterschaft zweiter ja
genau diese Weltmeister und da war dann
irgendwie für uns klar okay wir wollen
das wirklich vormachen nach der Matura
und dann war auch klar okay bis zum
Motorrad schau mal dass man halt viel
Beachvolleyball spielen aber halt auch
nur Halle und dann war klar nach dem
Mott immer gemeinsam nach Wien und auch
die national im Trainer haben gesagt sie
das nochmal und ja dann die nächsten
Jahre dann hast du ein Jahr vor mir
maturiert dann und dann war ich gerade
noch maturiert aber dann sind wir
eigentlich im Herbst zwei wenn man das
Herz zwei 13 sind wir gemeinsam nach
Wien gezogen und seit 19 Jahren
[Musik]
auch zum Bundeswehr gekommen und das
seitdem schon seit Oktober 2013 beim
Bundeswehr also wirklich sehr sehr lange
schon und wie gesagt ich glaube ohne
dass alles nicht möglich gewesen weil
ich bin dann nach Wien wie finanzierst
du dir auch eine Wohnung wie kannst du
dir das Leben leisten also das war schon
ich glaube einer der mit wichtigsten
Faktoren dass wir jetzt das sind wo wir
ja viel weil ich meine ohne die
Unterstützung hat man das einfach nicht
machen können das ist wirklich also
diese finanzielle Unabhängigkeit auch
von den Eltern das war für uns wirklich
ein extrem wichtiger Schritt sagen zu
können okay wir ziehen jetzt gemeinsam
nach Wien haben wirklich so vom
Bundesheer die Unterstützung wir können
uns auf dem Sport fokussieren müssen
nicht nebenbei irgendwie noch Geld
verdienen oder so und natürlich unsere
Eltern haben uns extrem zusätzlich
unterstützt auf finanziell aber das mit
dem Bundesheer war für uns wirklich der
Step so können wir es auch wirklich
professionell angehen ja wie wichtig war
der Schritt dass er sagt okay wir gehen
voll auf Beachball lassen weg oder kann
man das auch gemeinsam machen vielleicht
dann muss Energie nutzen im Training
oder beißt sich das eigentlich
was dann oder ist es eigentlich klar
dass man so 18 bis Matura finde ich es
ist schon sehr gut ausgebildet wird weil
man halt in der Halle viel mehr WE Hilfe
hat und ich habe von U11 Wettkämpfe
gespielt und das hast du den Beach wenn
es zu jung bist noch nicht viele
Turniere und da ist es gleich gut dass
man sich in der Halle noch die Wettkampf
Erfahrung holt oder auch diesen
Teamgeist und das prägt aber ich glaube
um diesen Dreh mit 18 herum würde ich
sagen es ist gut dass man sich entweder
für eine Halle oder für eine beachvolle
Bakterie entscheidet und damals für uns
auch klar wenn wir dann in Wien sind und
das professionell machen dann gibt's da
nur Beachvolleyball dass wir halt auch
unter der Woche täglich die trolleyball
trainieren im Winter auf trainingslage
können das wäre nicht möglich wenn wir
zugleich Halle spielen wir setzen zum
Volleyball gekommen das ist dann die
Katharina schon ein bisschen doppelt so
lange Alter
Volksschule ich bin schon sehr sportlich
und wollte eigentlich ältere Bruder
Fußball gespielt aber mein papa wollte
nicht unbedingt dass ein kleines Mädchen
Fußball spielt weil andere Sportarten
ausprobiert und tatsächlich an meinem 7
Geburtstag
Training eben beim TSV Hartberg macht
und bin dann sofort hängeblähm ich war
er schon ich weiß es ja groß für mein
Alter damals so
und da sind relativ motorisch auch schon
relativ geschickt und deswegen bin ich
dann beim Volleyball blieben habe aber
zugleich noch Dennis gespielt und in der
Schule dann Unterstufe auch ein bisschen
Fußball wieder leichtat